Since Twilight came out over a decade ago,
its stars have gone on to enjoy success in
both mainstream and indie film roles, while
others have transitioned into TV or moved
away from Hollywood entirely.
Here's what the cast has been up to in the
years since Twilight concluded.
She'd made movies before signing on for the
saga, but Kristen Stewart became an international
superstar overnight by starring as Bella in
the Twilight franchise.
She quickly landed other leading roles, including
starring in the Joan Jett biopic The Runaways.
Once she wrapped her time in the Twilight
series, she became a spokesperson for fashion
houses such as Chanel and Balenciaga.
She also had a small role in 2012's Into the
Wild.
Eventually, Stewart transitioned from starring
in blockbusters to working on smaller indie films.
In 2014, she starred in Camp X-Ray, receiving
critical acclaim for her portrayal of a guard
stationed at Guantanamo Bay.
She also co-starred with Chloë Sevigny in
2018's Lizzie, portraying Lizzie Borden's
lover and accomplice to the infamous killings
of Borden's father and stepmother.
Stewart has also tried her hand behind the
camera, writing and directing a short film,
Come Swim, in 2017.
After working consistently as an indie darling
for several years, Stewart reemerged as a
blockbuster force once again with starring
roles in 2019's Charlie's Angels and 2020's Underwater.
More recently, she starred in Hulu's Happiest
Season, playing Abby, a woman who is invited
to her girlfriend's home for the holidays.
As one of the first major holiday films to
center around a same-sex couple, Happiest
Season became a cultural touchpoint for discussions
about LGBTQ stories in film, all while stoking
passionate debate among viewers over who Stewart's
character should've ended up with.
Like his co-star Kristen Stewart, Robert Pattinson
also found success soon after starring in
the Twilight franchise, landing major roles
in Remember Me and Water for Elephants.
Both films received mixed reviews, but critics
praised Pattinson's clear attempt to move
away from teen idol roles - something that
would become a recurring theme as he continued
to build his post-Twilight career.
He also became the face of fashion house Dior
Homme's fragrance and menswear lines.
Throughout the 2010s, Pattinson appeared in
different roles in various genres outside
of the Twilight films, including the Safdie
brothers' thriller Good Time.
He went on to land several prominent roles
in 2019, including historical dramas The King
and Waiting for the Barbarians.
2020 also proved to be a productive time for
Pattinson, who starred in Christopher Nolan's
highly anticipated thriller Tenet, the first
major Hollywood release that opened in theaters
after initial shutdowns due to the COVID-19
pandemic.
In what might be his most anticipated role
to date, Pattinson landed the lead in The
Batman, donning the cowl set aside when Ben
Affleck vacated the role following Justice League.
Anna Kendrick had a small supporting role
in Twilight as Jessica Stanley, a high school
student who happily brings Bella into the
fold when she moves to Forks, Washington.
The year after she appeared in Twilight, she
had her own moment in the spotlight when she
starred in 2009's Up in the Air alongside
George Clooney, a role for which she was nominated
for an Academy Award, a Golden Globe, and
Screen Actors Guild award.
She went on to play a supporting role in Edgar
Wright's Scott Pilgrim vs. The World as Scott Pilgrim's sister Stacey.
"Who is this mystery child you date?"
"Her name's Knives Chau.
She's Chinese."
"A 17-year-old Chinese schoolgirl?"
In 2012, Kendrick became an even more recognizable
household name when she starred in Pitch Perfect.
She later reprised her role as Beca Mitchell,
an ambitious college student who strives to
be a music producer, in both Pitch Perfect
sequels.
She appeared in several musical roles in films
like The Last Five Years and Into the Woods,
drawing from her experience on Broadway prior
to her Twilight days.
In 2016, she had her first major voice acting
role when she portrayed Princess Poppy in Trolls.
She has most recently appeared in the black
comedy A Simple Favor and the holiday film Noelle.
In the Twilight saga, Kellan Lutz played Emmett
Cullen, Edward's buff and lovable adopted brother.
After this, he worked on a few horror films
such as After Dusk They Come and the 2010
remake of A Nightmare on Elm Street.
He also starred in a sports romance film,
A Warrior's Heart, alongside his Twilight
co-star Ashley Greene.
Shortly after his Twilight role wrapped, Lutz
portrayed several iconic characters in various
films, such as 2013's Tarzan and 2014's The
Legend of Hercules.
He also had a small part in the ensemble cast
of The Expendables 3 alongside Sylvester Stallone,
Mel Gibson, Jason Statham, and Harrison Ford.
In recent years, Lutz has found success working
in network TV.
He appeared in the CBS series FBI as FBI Special
Agent Kenny Crosby, and later starred in the
show's spin-off series FBI: Most Wanted.
Outside of acting, Lutz has done lots of charity
work.
He was named one of GQ's gentlemen of the
year in 2013 for his work with charity Saving
Innocence, which protects victims of child
sex trafficking.
Billy Burke had a small supporting role in
Twilight as Bella Swan's protective father
and Forks' police chief.
Shortly after his appearance in the first
Twilight film, he worked on several thrillers,
such as 2008's Untraceable and 2011's Drive
Angry.
He also worked with Twilight director Catherine
Hardwicke in 2011's Red Riding Hood, playing
the father of the film's titular character.
On television, Burke played Phillip Stroh,
a recurring antagonist on TNT's The Closer.
He reprised this role in spin-off series,
Major Crimes, until his character's death
in the series finale.
In 2012, Burke also starred in Revolution,
a sci-fi series that ran for two seasons on NBC.
The show received generally positive reviews
and had a passionate fanbase.
In 2020, Burke appeared in 9-1-1: Lone Star
as well as the Quibi series Most Dangerous Game.
He's also set to appear in the Netflix dramedy
series Maid.
Like his co-stars Kristen Stewart and Robert
Pattinson, Taylor Lautner was thrust into
the spotlight immediately following his appearance
in the first Twilight film.
Lautner played Bella's longtime friend and
love interest Jacob Black, who also happens
to be a werewolf.
In 2010, he was a member of the ensemble cast
of rom-com Valentine's Day.
In the film, Lautner's character, Willy, is
the love interest of Taylor Swift's character, Felicia.
In 2011, Lautner took the lead role in Abduction,
but the film was panned, with many critics
specifically criticizing Lautner's performance.
Lautner's other foray into being an action
lead, Tracers, similarly received negative reviews.
Despite Lautner's challenges in Hollywood,
he's found success in recent years on TV.
He had a main role on BBC's comedy series
Cuckoo for three seasons.
Lautner also had a main role in Ryan Murphy's
black comedy series Scream Queens.
In the years immediately following Jackson
Rathbone's appearance in the first Twilight
film as Jasper Hale, he appeared in horror
films such as Dread and Hurt.
In 2010, he also starred in M. Night Shyamalan's
live-action version The Last Airbender, which
was based on the beloved Nickelodeon animated
series.
The film faced widespread backlash for casting
white actors to portray characters who many
viewers believed were of East Asian or Inuit
descent.
In 2019, he starred in The Wall of Mexico
as Don, a handyman for a Mexican-American family.
The film was met with a mostly positive response
from critics, who also praised Rathbone's performance.
Apart from acting, Rathbone also started a
funk rock band called 100 Monkeys.
During the years the band was active, the
multitalented Rathbone played guitar, bass, and drums.
In 2012, he left the band when his then-girlfriend
Sheila Hafsadi gave birth to their first child.
He and Hafsadi later got married in 2013 and
have since had two more children.
Ashley Greene was a fan favorite in the Twilight
saga for her bubbly and charismatic portrayal of Alice Cullen.
Shortly after, she starred in Skateland, portraying
a teen who works at a Texas roller rink.
In 2011, she appeared alongside fellow Twilight
co-star Kellan Lutz in A Warrior's Heart and
was part of an all-star ensemble cast in Butter.
In 2012, she starred in the rom-com LOL as
Miley Cryus' high school nemesis, while also
appearing in various horror and thriller films
throughout the early 2010s -- including The
Apparition, Kristy, Burying the Ex, Urge,
and Accident Man.
On television, she had a main role on the
police procedural Rogue.
More recently, Greene starred in Hallmark
Channel's A Little Christmas Charm.
Aside from her on-screen work, she's also
done voice acting work for the Batman: Arkham
Knight video game.
Peter Facinelli played Carlisle Cullen, the
patriarch in the Cullen family in the Twilight film franchise.
Facinelli's most prominent and recognizable
role outside of Twilight was on the medical
series Nurse Jackie, where he played Dr. Fitch
Cooper, a charismatic but naive emergency
room doctor who flirts with the show's protagonist
Jackie.
He also had a recurring role on Glee as a
Broadway director running a revival of Funny Girl.
In 2015, he starred in NBC's American Odyssey,
a military thriller series.
Most recently, he starred in Escaping the
NXIVM Cult, a 2019 Lifetime movie that was
inspired by the real-life story of the NXIVM
sex cult led by Keith Raniere and Smallville
actress Allison Mack.
Facinelli has worked both on set and behind
the scenes.
For example, in 2011, he wrote, produced,
and starred in a romantic dramedy Loosies,
in which he played a free-spirited New York
pickpocket.
Before appearing in the Twilight films, Nikki
Reed made her first appearance on the big
screen in Catherine Hardwicke's film Thirteen,
for which she co-wrote the script with Hardwicke
when she was just a teenager.
Shortly after her appearance in Twilight,
she appeared in crime thriller Catch .44,
as well as numerous straight-to-DVD films.
In Reed's personal life, she's remained very
close friends with several of her Twilight co-stars.
She was even named the godmother of Jackson
Rathbone's firstborn child, Monroe Jackson Rathbone VI.
She's also started her own family with The
Vampire Diaries' Ian Somerhalder, giving birth
to their first child in 2017.
Outside of Hollywood, Reed started a sustainable
jewelry brand called BaYou [“by you”] With Love.
The company creates its jewelry by recycling
gold, including gold recovered from old electronics.
"Once you start thinking in this way, you
start questioning all the decisions you make."
Reed designs the brand's collections of wedding
rings and more casual, everyday jewelry herself.
Elizabeth Reaser played Esme, the Cullen matriarch
in the Twilight series.
Before this, she was perhaps best known for
her recurring role on Grey's Anatomy as Ava,
a patient who suffers from severe memory loss
and falls in love with Dr. Alex Karev.
Since her time on Twilight, Reaser has had
recurring and guest-starring roles on several TV shows.
She also starred in her own CBS series, The
Ex List, as Bella Bloom, a woman who must
revisit her past relationships to find her
soulmate.
The show was canceled after four episodes
due to poor ratings.
Aside from her work on the Twilight films,
Reaser's films have included Young Adult and Liberal Arts.
Most recently, she starred in Netflix's highly
acclaimed The Haunting of Hill House, a horror
series centered on a haunted mansion and the
family that lives in it.
Reaser played Shirley, the eldest daughter,
who owns a mortuary.
Gil Birmingham had one of the smaller roles
on Twilight as Billy Black, Jacob Black's
father and Charlie Swan's best friend.
Billy was a minor part in the first Twilight
film, but became a more significant character
once Jacob underwent his first werewolf transformation
in New Moon.
After Birmingham concluded his role in the
Twilight saga, he appeared in several films,
including 2013's The Lone Ranger and 2016's
Hell or High Water.
In 2017, he starred alongside Jeremy Renner
in Wind River, which received positive reviews
and reignited conversations surrounding Indigenous
representation in film.
On the small screen, Birmingham has had several
guest and recurring appearances across various
shows and networks.
He was a recurring actor on Netflix's hit
series House of Cards as Daniel Lanagin, a
U.S. Congressman and casino owner.
He also appeared on Netflix's comedy series
Unbreakable Kimmy Schmidt as the father of
Jane Krakowski's character.
Since 2018, he's starred in Paramount drama
Yellowstone, which follows the conflicts between
a ranch family, land developers, and Native
Americans who live on a nearby reservation.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
stuff are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.